all right everybody to celebrate the
renewal of richardson it's season two
i'm very excited i thought that we would
play a game
who would you rather in bridgeton we all
know this all ends with duke hastings
it's fine
who would you rather spend a day with at
an amusement park
eloise bridgerton or penelope
featherington oh that's hard i love
both i love penelope i do love eloise i
think she's fun
and just very kind of crazy in the best
sense like like
i think she's very strong and powerful
but i think penelope is sneaky powerful
and i really like her and she's all
heart i don't like how she like
you know outed but it's fine i know why
she did it
i would pick i would pick probably
pinella
i don't know maybe i'd pick eloise ah
let's pick both okay let's do it again
okay which bridgerton brother would you
rather have babysit your children
well this became a not fun who would you
rather
this became very mom version
okay babysit your children anthony
benedict or colin i'm picking
colin the youngest one because
well i don't know i don't know i really
like benedict too
um i'm gonna pick colin i like he's
sweet i like i like colin
who would you rather take on a
cross-country road trip
daphne bridgeton or marina thompson
i like marina yeah yeah i'm down i'm
down for hanging out with her
um although she like a bit shady trying
to trap a guy like that that's a bit
shady
i don't know she's trying to trap it but
you know what i think what we've learned
here women while watching bridgeton
while it can be hot and sexy be very
fortunate that you're alive right now
because holy
i would have died if somebody picked
who i if i got forced to marry some old
dude
like and then they didn't tell you what
stuff was like and they didn't tell you
because they knew then you'd know the
more you know
it's all i'm saying whose wardrobe would
you rather raid
queen charlotte or lady danbury i
love lady danbury i love her so much
they're so power so much power in her
and so
and so much grace i like her a lot but
she is
i don't know she kind of reminds me like
dixie carter from designing women
she she's bold i like her who would you
rather take home to meet your mom
once again very family-friendly version
um
or take home to meet my mom benedict
bridgeton or colin bridgeton
benedict bridgeton he's the artist yeah
so
i like that the painter and he went to
that freaky party
and he was like all right who would you
rather take to the pleasure garden
it gets interesting who would you rather
take to the pleasure garden
um is i don't even need to see any
noah no offense anthony bridger10
very awesome but you coming in the room
looking like duke hastings and being all
like
smaller like duke hastings and like when
he was in the garden and stuff
like okay um i might have seen that one
episode like a few times
but yeah i was like and then you knew
she was running in that garden
you know she was like oh don't follow me
and then she like really wanted him to
follow her
and then it was like and then the
brother came and ruined it
because it was no fun to be a female
back then i'm just saying anyway
be very happy that you are live right
now
thank you to all the women that have
fought for our rights
to just be human all right have a good
one
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever